الشارع الاسرائيلي اسبابه كثيره وطبعا
قانون التعديلات القضائيه وقوده تم تاجيله
فقط وليس الغائه تحت الضغوط وقوه الشارع
لكن اقرار الميزانيه يبدو انه منح نتنياهو
دفعه اضافيه اكد بعد الاقرار ان القانون
سيعود الى اجنده الحكومه
سنستمر بجهودنا من اجل الوصول الى توافق
كبير بما يتعلق بالاصلاح القضائي
تصريحاته استفزت المعارضه احد قادتها
بانيجانس وهو وزير الدفاع السابق قال نصا
اذا عاد القانون
سنزلزل الدوله
وسنوقف مشروع التعديلات القضائيه هذه
الاحتجاجات ليست ملكا خاصا لي او لاي شخص
سياسي لا اعتقد ان المتظاهرين سيسمح لنا
او لنتنياهو باللعب معهم واعتقد ان ردهم
سيكون بشكل ملائم كان اقرار الميزانيه منح
نتنياهو دفعه فكلمته جانس هذه مدفوعه بدعم
الشارع التظاهرات مستمره منذ خمسه اشهر
وحتى الان والهتافات واحده
ناتي للتظاهر كل اسبوع ناتي لان هذا مهم
لانه ليست لدينا دوله اخرى لان الناس
يحاولون السيطره على نظامنا وتحويله الى
شيء سيء لفرض اشياء لا نؤمن بها مثل
كراهيه الاجانب وحرمان الاقليات من لتغيير
ميزان كل ما هو موجود هنا وتدميري مستقبل
البلاد
الى هنا للتظاهر اسبوعيا في الشهرين او
الثلاثه اشهر الماضيه اتيت الى هنا نيابه
عني ونيابه عن والدي اريد ان احافظ على
هذا البلد بالطريقه التي تم تاسيسها بها
ويمكننا القيام بذلك معا
في الواقع هذا هو الاسبوع الحادي والعشرون
الذين ياتي فيه للتظاهر كل ليله السبت من
اجل مستقبل بلدنا والتظاهر من اجل
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه والتظاهر من اجل
مستقبل امتنا كدوله ديمقراطيه حره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات